[Music]
we're here to announce the arrest of 10
individuals who are responsible for a
drug trafficking organization
that is operating or was operating in
the central florida area
the volusia bureau of investigations
mission is to identify disrupt or
dismantle drug trafficking organizations
that operate in our area responsibility
and in this case they did just that
christina guess we are alleging that she
is the
ringleader of what we term the guests
organization
and throughout her time
operating this organization we believe
that they trafficked up to 24 pounds of
methamphetamine within a one year period
our vbi agents were successful in
infiltrating this organization through
surveillance and ultimately through
electronic surveillance and identified
nine other members to include her source
of supply
that are responsible for bringing
methamphetamine into volusia county
this is christina guess
she's a former prison guard she worked
for the state of florida for 12 years
we investigated her a few years ago as
well
for trafficking meth in center to prison
and we intend to send her back
another individual that we had
identified in this investigation is a
female by the name of andrea dunmeyer
in december of last year we went to her
house where her infant child was found
deceased
we began an investigation into that
matter and determined that that child
died as a result of methamphetamine
toxology
we're not sure exactly how that occurred
our homicide detectives are continuing
that investigation and we're working
with the state attorney's office to hold
her accountable for that we don't
believe that it was an intentional act
but likely through neglect so this this
organization
obviously has some violence tied into it
and some of the children that were
involved in in some of these houses
we've removed them with the help of dcf
um
this way
all right
i'll come back
what is going on you have a warrant for
your arrest for what i'm going to tell
you in just a moment okay and you just
said a brake light yeah i did
oh oh come on now that hurts my wrist
well don't hold your hands like that oh
you had him like that i'm sorry
my boyfriend's just pulling in the yard
okay no right there oh that's not your
boyfriend my boyfriend
what is that clearly she's secured
[Music]
you have an id in your car yes sir okay
um
bless my feet
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
well
you guys know roughly when it expired
[Music]
all right that's
still going eastbound
should be coming up those as garfield
where he should be turning that roughly
he's turning southbound on osceola
might have a bailout
white male
i think he just threw something out the
window right by the child's at play
yellow sign
uh he's still going we're coming up to
uh waltz
all right he's turning westbound
westbound waltz
he's still moving all around the car
we're coming to a stop in here uh he's
going to try to go around me 12-0
he's stuck he's stuck
hands up get your hands up put your
fucking hands up
don't you move don't you fucking move
open the car door
open the car door
come on over here guys
keep your hands out the window keep your
hands out the window
no i got them at gunpoint standby
keep your hands out the window
[Music]
come out of the car go down to the
ground get down on the ground put your
hands behind your back put your hands
behind your back
don't move just stay just like that all
right
all right he's securing slow it down
the fuck you doing nothing sir
you got any guns or anything on you man
get back up on your knees
come up on this can i get you up like
this dude you're too big for me to lift
on
come on stay just like that
i assure you that if you're out there
trafficking drugs in our communities
it's only a matter of time before we're
kicking in your front door and you're
going to jail